[Music]
the transformers franchise has been a
long-term hit in the movie business for
almost 15 years now in recent weeks the
pr machine for the upcoming seventh part
has been running at full speed and has
given us a few surprises
in today's original episode we introduce
you to the recently announced news
as well as the current progress the team
behind the film
and a lot more infos so sit back and
enjoy our preview for the upcoming
transformers
rise of the beasts
first let's take a look at the plot
especially michael bay fans should get
their money's worth here even though
he's not even the director
it sounds strange at first but producer
lorenzo di buenaventura has confirmed
several times that rise of the beasts
will be a similar spectacle to michael
bay's transformers films
he said the main goal is to return to
the origins of the franchise and to what
the film series is known
for entertaining action at the center of
attention will be the world famous
optimus prime who will once again be
dubbed by his original voice actor peter
cullen
unlike the bane movies and the animated
series where prime is already known as
the protector of earth
the leader of the autobots in rise of
the beast is not expected to have
any real connection to earth yet it is
only in this film that he will develop a
protective instinct alongside his
autobot friends
at this point we can most likely count
on many new friendships between robots
and humans just as we are used to from
the prequels
the main characters on the human side
are elna and noah
the two new yorkers are not exactly on
the bright side of life and
desperately try to keep their heads
above water elena played by dominic
fishback is a full-time artifact
researcher and is suffering from a toxic
working environment
her boss is mainly driven by money and
seems to have little interest
in her loving work noah is played by
anthony ramos and is a battle-hardened
veteran
he must look after his mother and his
little brother and he has to work hard
to give them both a modest life at the
poverty line
his strong point is working with
electronic devices which he enjoys using
to repair a wide variety of things
with both main characters their talents
will certainly come in handy especially
in dealing with the transformers
of course the decepticons do not come up
short in transformer 7 either
they are not the only competitors of the
autobots however as their
other strong enemies the maximals the
predacons
and the terracons although the maximals
are descendants of the autobots and also
have a lot in common with optimus prime
and the like
they are a civilian race that is
essentially dedicated to democratic
values and peace
the most significant difference from the
autobots is probably the beast mode
where they can transform into organic
beans like mammals and birds
in doing so they have artificial organic
skin as well as all sorts of animal
instincts
their leader is optimus primal not to be
confused with the main character optimus
prime of course
the second grouping is the predacons
they are descendants of the decepticons
and rose from the ashes of the great war
they are ranked lower in the hierarchy
than the maximals which is why many
predacons are not so fond of them
they can transform into animal forms as
well but they prefer to take the form of
amphibians or reptiles
another characteristic is their
transformation into sea creatures
and military vehicles last but not least
there are the terracons
these are undead transformers that are
made out of dark anergon
some versions can't even suck energon
from other transformers to become
stronger themselves
in a larger group they're almost
unstoppable though not
invulnerable the best chance of
defeating a terracon is by slashing them
into as many small pieces as possible
as this makes the dark anagon as good as
ineffective
they don't have a real mind and try to
destroy everything in their way
so not too easy of an opponent by the
way
a return of bumblebee is also to be
expected because its director stephen
cable jr and producer lorenzo de bruyne
ventura announced
that blockbuster takes place in 1994
and the seven years after the events of
bumblebee
the setting chosen is primarily new york
city or rather it's borough brooklyn
when one hears of 1994
and brooklyn there's of course no
getting around the prevailing hip-hop
culture
and who knows there may even be
references to the actual greats of that
time
such as the notorious b.i.g or most
death moreover
there is also the southern hemisphere
pero to be precise
there the legendary inca city of machu
picchu is likely to be the focus of
particular attention and we really hope
that the centuries old wonder of the
world
will not suffer major damage
in addition to the human actors there
are also some newcomers among the robots
which we would like to introduce to you
now
we'll start with optimus primal whom we
already introduced as the leader of the
maximals
he was the leader of a research vessel
that went of course while chasing a
pratikon ship
and the predicament ship said none other
than megatron by the way
in terms of character the steely gorilla
is very down to earth
and this in spite of the fact that he
likes to talk big
of course this doesn't mean that he
won't use any means to cope with a risky
situation for he always finds a solution
no matter how unusual it may be in him
his friends have a loyal partner while
even his foes are often treated with a
fair amount of respect
another new character is eraser she
belongs to the maximals flies around
kinda carefree
and is mainly used for reconnaissance
and surveillance
her incredibly sharp eyesight is very
helpful here which paired with her
accurate aiming skills
brings many opponents to their knees her
nature is quite tranquil but depending
on the situation it is also paired with
a good sense of humor
incidentally she sees rynox a giant
rhinoceros who's also a newcomer
as her great father figure rhinox is a
massive and intelligent companion that
you wouldn't want to have as an
enemy despite his amiable nature flowers
are his marked preference
in fact there's nothing he likes better
than a relaxing
afternoon in a bath he is close friends
with optimus primal and could arguably
lead the maximals with east should he
want to that said
the autobots also have newcomers one of
them is the female transformer arki who
has joined the defense force on
cybertron
she is considered very rational among
the autobots and is a pleasant
contemporary
mirage is also part of the mix albeit no
longer has the iconic ferrari 458 but
instead in the form of a blue and silver
striped porsche 911
he is rather anti-authoritarian in
nature and often also a fellow
decepticon sympathizer
as a final new addition we introduce you
to the new main villain of transformer 7
namely scourge he's a decepticon who was
pieced together from
other dead decepticons by unicron in
part 7 he appears to be the leader of
the terracons and he's
incredibly powerful
let's move on to our last subject the
production
as we already mentioned the director
will no longer be michael bay
but stephen cable jr the 33 year old has
already achieved some success with creed
2 and will now put his skills to the
test
with the new transformers producer
lorenzo di buenaventura who has been
involved in the franchise since its
beginning
will be assisting him currently
transformers
rise of the beasts is still in a fairly
early production stage
since the first official photo shoots
were taken just under a month ago in los
angeles
and are being continued in machu picchu
that's it again with our most recent
video did you like our preview if so
please leave us a big thumbs up
and subscribe join us next wednesday for
our newest episode
see you next time
you